au québec un groupe de jeunes noirs
rassemblés dans un parc à la tombée de
la nuit on appelle ça
les amis québécois
je veux être vu l'une de ses publicités
à la télé ou sur le web en fait sa
déclinaison de différentes situations
cette nouvelle campagne publicitaire du
gouvernement du québec pour lutter
contre le racisme le mettre fin aux
préjugés arrive il faut bien le
connaître dans un contexte où le nombre
de dossiers notamment pour le profilage
racial ouvert à la commission des droits
de la personne et des droits de la
jeunesse est en augmentation depuis
trois ans je vous donne ma ces chiffres
en 2019 on en comptait 46 et maintenant
en 2020 21 ses 86 dossiers qui ont été
ouverts mais ces publicités n'est
certainement d'une bonne intention
provoque beaucoup de réaction écrit chez
certains un grand malaise alors est ce
que c'est une campagne qui rate sa cible
là on en parle avec le réalisateur quoi
les recruter pour faire cette campagne
bonsoir monsieur quoi les îles martin
saint victor en stratège en
communication et directeur général de
lehman montréal vincent martin saint
victor merci d'être avec nous alors vous
allez peut-être nous dire quand vous
avez vu la publicité en nombre vous avez
tout de suite écrit une lettre genre je
vais en donner un extrait donc au
gouvernement bien malgré moi une lettre
d'excusés au fond sur facebook bien
malgré moi j'ai contribue à la
fabrication d'un message publicitaire
discriminatoire je m'incline et m'excuse
vous benoit charette et françois legault
je vous demande de retirer cette
publicité de vous excuser pourquoi
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qui ne va pas
selon vous avec ses publicités qui
diffusait maintenant tant de choses
mais en fait j'ai adressé leurs excuses
parce que c'est pas le concept pour
lequel je m'étais engagé lorsqu'on m'a
approché pour réaliser cette pub et
puisqu'il faut comprendre c'est que
quelques jours avant la mise en ondes
ont été en ce qu'on appelle en montage
offline la finalisation du projet le
client dans ce cas ci le goût dans le
gouvernement à changer un mot en fait a
ajouté le mot québécois et québécoises
cet adjectif là pour moi venu dénaturer
complètement le message est ouvert une
conversation a fait dérailler en fait le
message initial du projet et qu'elle
était justement votre concept lui le but
de cette campagne puisque en ajoutant
selon vous le mot québécois ça rendait
la publicité
presque dix ans une cible au contraire
la base est devenu campagne politique
pour moi c'est devenu une campagne
nationale ici c'est devenu une campagne
d' intégration plutôt qu'une campagne de
sensibilisation
au départ sans le mot québécois on
finissait en disant mais voilà ce sont
des familles ce sont des amis ce sont
des humains moi c'est comme ça que je le
lis et ce que je vois à l'écran ce qui
est en nombre c'est c'est tout autre
chose qu'on dit présentement si vous ne
voulez pas être comme considère si vous
voulez pas être une victime de racisme
portées cette identité québécoise
et ça pour moi ça vient vraiment faire
dérailler complètement le concept
initialement c'était simplement sans le
mot québécois bien sûr bien sûr on peut
on peut critiquer de ce concept en
disant effectivement on évoque on
perpétue des préjugés
je le vois
aujourd'hui je le voyais pas avant mais
en même temps ce qu'il faut comprendre
aussi c'est ce concept a été s'adresse
principalement un groupe très
spécifiques on a reçu jeudi au mais je
parle pour l' agence lagence de création
a reçu en fait une étude un sondage fait
auprès des québécois et québécoises et
30% de ces individus se sont
autoproclamés un peu ou raciste donc
c'est plus blanc s'adresse
spécifiquement à cette communauté là
lorsqu'on vient de faire en fait qu on
ajoute deux mots québécois c'est qu'on
ne s'adresse plus à ces gens là on est
en train de s'adresser à ses communautés
et on leur dit moi en tout cas d'origine
vietnamienne ce que je reçois c'est au
québec vous devez porter cette identité
loin si vous ne voulez pas vivre ces
préjugés oui pour vous montrer sa
victoire quelle lecture faites-vous de
cette impression local monsieur qu aller
comme réalisateur parce que on sait on
connaît la politique nationaliste et
identitaire du gouvernement se veut
selon grandement très inclusive alors
comment avez-vous réagi vous à cette
publicité
je les trouvais maladroite je pense que
l'intention était certainement vol la
preuve c'est cesser d'avoir avec le
monsieur liés dans la dans sa création
je crois que lorsque le réalisateur dit
que ce n'était pas du tout l'intention
mais alors il faut pas attendre il faut
là il faut retirer cette publicité ce
qui a été fait en anglais et ce qui est
particulier c'est que en anglais il n'y
avait pas le mot québécois donc on a pu
faire une comparaison mais en les
comparant se disait en anglais ce sont
que des amis ça veut dire que quoi qu'on
les considère pas québécois parce qu'ils
sont anglophones alors quand je pensais
il y avait le mot québécois donc déjà il
ya sept
cette incompréhension parce que le
message n'est pas le même et en anglais
on a retiré tout de suite et je suis un
peu surprise de voir que malgré la
demande du réalisateur malgré le
mécontentement et je tiens à souligner
que le mécontentement ne vient pas
seulement de membres issus des
communautés qu'on voit dans ses
publicités ce mécontentement est assez
générales et ça je pense qu'il faut le
mentionner parce que d'un côté il faut
l'applaudir c'est une preuve que le
boulaire gouvernement avait sous-estimé
la sophistication des québécois nous a
sous-estimé dans notre perception de la
réalité et aussi de l'importance du
message
et je pense que quand le réalisateur dit
je vous demande de retirer la publicité
ya plus rien à dire il n'y a plus rien à
dire mais le gouvernement la main c'est
toujours ce qu elle est le gouvernement
lui n'a pas l'impression de rater sa
cible de toute évidence il veut envoyer
le message que tous les citoyens vivent
ici quelle que soit leur origine sont
des québécois
moi je veux quand même préciser en fait
je au moment où on se parle moi j'ai des
doutes par rapport aux intentions du
gouvernement parce que les flashs les
élevé avant la mise en ondes mais mon
argumentaire et s'est déployée et celui
de l'argent ce aussi bien avant j'ai
vraiment souligner de manière très
évidente tous les risques de dérapage
avec ça donc on m'a pas écouté on ne m'a
pas consulté alors que je suis la
personne concernée ou une des rares
personnes concernées qui fait partie en
fait de l'équipe de création et de
production
je tenais à dire ça puis j'ai manqué
votre question fixe ou faisait juste la
répéter non même en même temps c'est ça
c'est quoi au fond c'est qu'en disant
aux gens ça fait que ces messages que
tout sommes tous québécois quelle que
soit notre origine c'est un peu celui du
dès qu'ils se cachaient derrière
l'intention du gouvernement j'imagine
mais on met plus d'une chose on est
frères on y sert moi quand je suis avec
ma famille le soir je me dis poche
québécois je peux être ce que je veux on
est multiple et là on fasse une adhésion
en fait un sentiment d'appartenance à
une fierté québécoise on parle pas ici
d'une pub de pots de yogourt ou de porte
là on parle ici d'une campagne de
sensibilisation faite par notre
gouvernement
et lorsque comme vous le dites on vous
dit le réalisateur mais c'est pas c'est
pas juste le réalisateur s'est toutes
les personnes qui ont travaillé sur ce
concept 10 ne sortait pas ça ne m'était
pas ça en ligne ça c'est le backlash
s'est faite quelques heures après la
mise en onde donc je doute j'hésiterais
ouvertement mais je dois vraiment des
intentions je le demande vraiment si une
campagne
politique pensée réfléchie est
intéressant de voir madame série tant
que monsieur coué nous dit dans le fond
ont changé de cible en ajoutant
seulement ont changé de ces bons parler
plus seulement aux 30% de personnes qui
se reconnaissaient
disons 'peut-être avec des préjugés
racistes world on s'adressait aux
communautés c'est un message qu'on
envoie aux communautés plutôt que
sensibiliser les personnes qui auraient
des préjugés jeux comme wii message
inverse
et puis aussi je pense que le problème
qu'on vit est conçu ligne 2 qui est
soulignée depuis quelques années c'est à
dire le problème de racisme systémique
n'a rien à voir avec la fierté n'a rien
à voir si avec monsieur avec ma fierté
ou la fierté de monsieur l'est où la
fierté des gens qui sont représentés
dans cette multi citer dans ses
publicités ça n'a rien à voir avec ça le
racisme systémique c'est autre chose
c'est le problème qu'on en fait qui doit
être réglé aujourd'hui c'est la base et
d'avoir un gouvernement qui refuse de le
reconnaître qu'ils refusent même de le
nommer et que soudainement qu'il se
positionne comme étant spécialiste de la
nomenclature en disant comment les
infirmières doivent est comment va
appeler les infirmières comment on doit
appeler les amis je pensais un peu
maladroit et le problème n'est pas là le
problème n'est pas dans la fierté
québécoise s'est pas c'est parce qu'on
essaie de régler et puis vous savez
quand cette campagne publicitaire fait
partie des nombreuses recommandations
c'est à dire évidemment qu'on doit
passer par les médias évidemment qu'on
doit passer par la télévision et par le
web donc ça fait partie de l'une des
recommandations c'est certain c'est un
orchestre c'est plusieurs plusieurs
solutions en fait qu'on doit mettre de
l'avant et celle là pour moi c'est la
plus importante parce qu'elle donne le
temps c'est la première il a le temps
est complètement ratée et puis ces
publicités sont parodiés donc on prend
une situation qui est sérieuse un
problème qu'on a et b qui est sérieux et
elle est parodié parce que on ne se
reconnaît pas et et je pense que il a
quand on en arrive à la fin a redit
comme ça il faut retirer ses publicités
et puis en retirant ses publicités la ce
enverrait un message parce que de les
garder en on envoie aussi un message le
message pour moi si on vous entend pas
nous on sait qu'on a raison et on va de
l'avant merci à la victoire 10 secondes
pour moscou allait envisagez vous
d'autres gestes que la demande d'
excuses avec cette lettre
moi je demande non non je pense que le
message est assez clair communauté ont
parlé je demande le retrait pour toutes
les personnes qui ont participé aux six
qui sont khalid rang présentement et je
tiens aussi à m'excuser parce que j'ai
contribué à tout ça mais je demande à
notre immédiat merci beaucoup monsieur
quale merci martin saint victor mais je
vous garde la part la pause un autre
sujet d'actualité avec vous merci merci
à tous les deux merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit